bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi 11 à
descendre peintures sculptures
customisation pour son deuxième salon
des arts la ville de plaisir a convié
une douzaine d'artistes au sein du
château la poésie s'ouvre au public à
nouveau versailles et le poète didier
qu'un remède cet art à l'honneur un
nouveau cycle de lectures rencontre est
prévue tout au long de l'année du
théâtre pour dénoncer les violences
faites aux femmes la pièce des coûts et
du silence a été présenté à trappes pour
sensibiliser et échanger pensons 9e
salon la ville de plaisir accueille
douze artistes et invités d'honneur du
travail à partir de matériaux recyclés à
la peinture en passant par de la gravure
le salon regroupe tous les styles
artistiques des oeuvres à découvrir dans
la salle
armande béjart du château
monte monte monte toujours plus haut
pour voir le monde à la recherche d'une
certaine tranquillité et de l'entr'aide
en créant vu dans anno frachon chercher
de la magie pour voir au delà c voire
d'un os tout ce qui se passe en bas
c'est éviter éviter tout ce qui est
douloureux
c'est
c'est la proche de la beauté de la
légèreté elle représente la pureté et
pour faire cette colonne de coussins
c'était indispensable pour moi d'avoir
dû du blanc si je l'avais fait en pierre
ou en béton ça n'aurait pas dû tout
donner la même chose comme ndo frachon
11 autres artistes sont exposés le 9e
salon des arts de plaisir laisse une
grande place aux artistes yvelinois
comme fabienne dû mouiller a passionné
de musique qui travaillent des matériaux
recyclés des guitares destiné à la
destruction revivent entre ses mains dès
que j'ai commencé j'ai trouvé que les
arrondis se prêtait à vraiment très
facilement à la décoration et la
difficulté de suivre un contour qui
n'est pas rectiligne
c'est presque là la motivation et
petite réflexion sur le plein et le vide
une image fractionné implique un contour
et ce contour doit être l'intérieur
d'une autre image
une treizième artistes alimente
l'exposition véronique l'avenir est
l'invité d'honneur de cette nouvelle
édition
cette sculptrice travaille le bronze
pour des oeuvres où l'humain fragile
cherche sa place et des prix du jury et
du public seront remis ce dimanche 16
décembre
six auteurs francophones vont mettre la
poésie au premier plan transmission de
savoirs partage d'inspiration c'est
l'idée de poésie ouverte alors cette
deuxième saison débute dès demain le
mercredi 12 décembre 10 des cas m
bonjour je leur voue diriger ces
rencontres c'est une deuxième saison
est ce qu'on peut dire que la première a
été un succès ah oui c'est nous y aurait
pas eu de deuxième saison donc il faut
remercier tout de suite le maire de
versailles françois de mazières et jean
marie gilbert qui est l'attaché culture
directeur des affaires culturelles qui
m'ont proposé de continuer l'aventuré
s'est bien passé l'année dernière je
crois il ya eu du monde et surtout une
grande qualité qualité de dépôt est
d'abord avec une très belle parole
qualité d'écouté merveilleuse de la part
des auditeurs et qualité des changes
parce que c'est un peu ça l'idée
les poètes viennent présenter leur
travail lire leur travail qu'on les
entende
et puis ensuite naturellement le public
est là pour dialoguer et pour réagir et
parfois ce qui était un peu vif il n'y a
pas eu forcément de consensus il faut
pas croire que la poésie c'est le monde
des bisounours
le poésie ça veut dire aussi qu'il ya
des points de vue à défendre ça veut
dire aussi qu'il y a un état d'esprit sa
vision consentement c'est toujours
contemporain est une bonne question
j'espère j'espère mais je crois non je
crois ça va l'idée de la poésie est un
petit peu effectivement des yeux est
parfois parce que on a un peu trop
rester à l'école les récitations ne
regarde parfois de mauvais souvenirs
parfois de très beaux mais la poésie
c'est vraiment autre chose maintenant
une multiplicité d'auteur qui font
entendre des voix
je crois qu'il faut assimiler la poésie
à une voix c'est voir comme celle de
rimbaud il ya très longtemps est
absolument reconnaissable entre toutes
c'est pareil
leurs contemporains sont des voix qu'on
essaye d'entendre qu'on fait entendre
comment vous est venue l'idée de
proposer ses lectures c'est aussi un
moyen de rendre de faire découvrir la
poésie à tous deux dépassé le cadre
scolaire comme vous le dites
alors j'espère où il ya les petits
aspects techniques
au départ j'ai une résidence d'écrivain
par ailleurs je suis responsable d'une
chronique de poésie au monde donc déjà
avec la la tentation l'idée l'envi même
de faire partager la poésie la chronique
du monde s'appelle transpo esi ça veut
dire en vérité que on est très attaché à
une idée classique de la poésie mais en
même temps la poésie diffuse la poésie
s'ouvre à d'autres domaines la poésie
elle est l'un dès qu'il y a un
cet avis non pas d'utiliser la langue
comme on le fait en ce moment pour
échanger une simple communication
elle est là dès qu'il y à l'envi de
parler la langue des filiales envie de
creuser les mots d'equidia longue vie et
la possibilité de faire entendre des
silences de les faire résonner c'est
tout ça proche de la musique aussi
évidemment lors de ces rencontres il y a
six poètes qui vont participer vous êtes
le 6e vous faites le rendez vous le 15
mai le public pourra vous écoutez ce
soir là le premier rendez vous c'est dès
demain le 12 décembre à 19h à la
bibliothèque centrale de versailles dans
un écrin assez particulier et le poète
invité à des latif labit prix goncourt
de la poésie en 2009
oui abdellatif laâbi c'est un marocain
et je suis content de commencer
finalement quelqu'un qui est francophone
au 6 mai hab et au départ évidemment bon
il a une vie compliquée dans les années
soixante dix il a été pendant huit ans
en prison il ça était probablement un
moment fort de de son rapport à la
poésie et ce qui me plaît chez la bille
qui est très significative de la poésie
c'est que même si c'est la douleur de
l'emprisonnement qui bien entendu
emprisonnement parce qu'ils luttaient
contre le régime à l'époque c'est pas
pour je ne sais quelle autre motif
soyons clairs et en même temps toute sa
poésie est véritablement un message
d'espoir c'est une célébration de la vie
donc cette espèce d'alliance entre la
douleur qui est à l'origine du cri
poétique et puis 7
alchimie j'aime pas le mot qui est un
peu convenue mais enfin cette façon
qu'il a de transformer cette douleur on
a inscrit 10 points c'est formidablement
encore une fois l'esprit et la lettre et
la lettre de la poésie
vous le verrez il faut venir demain pour
partager pour dialoguer et vous verrez
c'est quelque chose qui est très
accessible
moi ce qui m'inquiète toujours c'est
l'idée qu'on a que la poésie est un truc
par ben être réservé aux initiés un truc
voilà non non pas du tout la fait vivre
ont fait partager
c'est un partage c'est exactement ça
c'est un partage de vie avec des mots
avec un amour des mots avec un amour de
la langue
j'espère l'amour de l'autre aussi et de
la vie encore une fois il ya quelque
chose d'assez spirituel aussi un dans
l'exercice poétique
il y aura d'autres auteurs aussi bruno
doucey valérie rouzeau charlie charles
pendant juillet patrick kéchichian
l'idée aussi c'est qu'ils parlent d'un
grand ancêtre qui parle leur inspiration
à eux c'est très important
on essaye aussi de faire on tente donc
ces paroles actuel qui résonne avec le
monde contemporain
mais bien entendu ça vient pas de nulle
part la poésie a une histoire et aux
demandes à chaque poète de présenter
aussi rapidement et mettre un de ses
inspirateurs
abdellatif laâbi son maître ou un de ses
maîtres en tout cas c'est aimé césaire
grand poète qui vivait à la martinique
est un homme politique enfin voila il
nous faut bien demain pour savoir qui
était plus précis alors cette année
aussi une particularité vous allez à la
rencontre de lycéens notamment pour des
ateliers d'écriture il faut partager à
être est aussi oui et c'est pas stade et
c'était déjà ça fait sept ans dernier
mais oui mais oui oui non c'est très
important
le lycée hoche est complètement parties
prenantes proviseur les professeurs il
ya trois professeurs cette année qui
embarquent leurs classes de seconde et
première et les mêmes auteurs donc ce
que vous venez de nommer viendront une
première fois rencontré les lycéens
demain matin il ça s'est pas ouvert au
public c'est bien on rêvait poésie ça
fait rêver
cent vingt élèves seront réunis dans le
grand amphithéâtre du lycée hoche pour
rencontrer abdellatif laâbi
et l'année dernière il était tellement
bouleversée par ce qu'ils ont entendu
qu'ils ont fait un spectacle de poésie
en fin d'année un vrai spectacle de
poésie c'est pas un truc un peu un peu
patronage comme ça et non non c'est cet
ep en ce début à la fin et
professionnels vraiment formidablement
on est un peu pressés par le temps
malheureusement mais pour écouter poèmes
et surtout échanger que les auteurs
notez bien les rendez-vous un par mois
jusqu'en mai et le premier c'est le 12
décembre merci beaucoup dickens de
toutes ces précisions
merci à vous et la poésie est aussi au
rendez vous sur saint quentin en
yvelines deux dates à noter dans vos
agendas alors du côté de plaisir elle se
vit en langue des signes
des poètes sourds se rencontrent à
l'ancien restaurant du château pour une
lecture rencontre et une projection à
guyancourt le compositeur aurélien m
maestra si le chef de choeur flavien
bois et le directeur d itinéraire
poétique japonais animeront un concert
commenté autour d'un célèbre poète
charles baudelaire
après les commémorations de la première
guerre mondiale vont débuter celle de la
seconde
et à cette occasion les archives
départementales des yvelines ont décidé
de créer un jeu de plateau autour de la
résistance en seine et oise
le public est amené à contribuer à ce
projet en créant lui-même son jeu la
première séance avait lieu la semaine
dernière regard des soirées studieuses
sans yvelinois découvre le monde du jeu
de société du produit fini à la création
première étape avant de créer soi-même
son jeu auteur autrice de jeux de
société c'est vraiment un métier c'est
un savoir faire et comme tout métier
tout savoir-faire bassa se découvre et
ça s'apprend donc nous c'est vrai qu'on
a on n'a pas la prétention de dire que
on va faire en sorte que les gens
deviennent hauteur au tri sans quelques
ateliers
mais l'idée c'est qu'ils puissent
découvrir un peu
les rouages les mécanismes faut penser à
toutes vos pensées à tous mais surtout à
ses joueurs et à ses joueuses deux ans
de travail sont nécessaires dans le
monde professionnel
ces participants auront quelques mois
pour réfléchir autour de la résistance
créé un jeu sur la thématique de
l'histoire ça faisait deux choses
vraiment intéressantes qui m'ont poussé
à participer
je trouve ça intéressant quand même de
voir comment on adapte justement un
thème dans derrière des mécaniques de
jeu comme on intéresse les participants
les joueurs au thème via le jeu en avril
ils présenteront un jeu historique
autour de réseaux la version plateau
pensé par les archives départementales
et conçu par un professeur d'histoire
géographie
on va mettre en exergue en fait dans ce
jeu la difficulté est de résister le
fait que c'était extrêmement compliqué
de se procurer les moyens de résister
bien sûr on était face à l'adversité on
pouvait risquer de se faire arrêter
voire pire donc là c est la dangerosité
qu'on essaie de faire passer et les
typologies de d'action qu'on pouvait
faire de la propagande à savoir
distribuer simplement des tracts jusqu'à
des actions armées du sabotage de plus
grande envergure réseau doit sortir pour
la fin de l'année 2019 mais il pourrait
évoluer avec les idées fournil par
l'atelier 11 autres séances sont prévues
la prochaine est organisée le mercredi
12 décembre une pièce de théâtre pour
dénoncer les violences faites aux femmes
des coûts et du silence écrit par
georges de cagliari et mise en scène par
sara veyron aborde ces violences sous
plusieurs aspects la soirée s'est
conclue par un débat théâtralisée
organisé par la ville de trappes manon
varaldo un homme pour en représenter
plusieurs que reconnaissent les femmes
victimes de violences elle cette marque
en viennent au prince
oui mais c'était de la faute des coûts
et du silence cette pièce s'engage dans
la lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes
l'occasion d'en voir toutes ses formes
et tous ses aspects à travers la pièce
on va aborder à la fois les violences
conjugales mais également aussi les
violences dans le monde professionnel et
la sphère également la sphère publique
puisque on va parler aussi des
transports en commun donc on a dans la
pièce un panel assez large de la société
et des situations de violence vécue par
les cendres 80 % des femmes en situation
de handicap ont été victimes de
violences une situation dénoncée à
travers cette pièce certains individus
et y en avait 1 ce matin se croient
autorisés à avoir à mon égard des gestes
discrètement déplacer assurer qu'ils
sont que malté cité ne m'aime permettra
pas de les identifier quatre victimes
sur cinq ne porte pas plainte la pièce
rappelle l'importance du rôle des
associations
j'ai vécu exactement la même chose que
vous votre vie tourne autour de de la
violence et de l'humeur de votre tyran
n'être plus qu'une chose qui tremble
l'arbre âme aux témoignages des
violences physiques mais aussi
psychologiques reprises dans la pièce un
constat prenant pour les comédiens ça
interroge les mécanismes même au
quotidien qu'on peut rencontrer aussi en
soi de ce qui rabaisse tout ce qui
diminue ce qui fait de soi un objet donc
il ya beaucoup de choses qui résonne mon
texte
après la pièce des coûts et du silence
du théâtre interactif les spectatrices
ont pu se mettre en scène avec les
comédiens concernant les thèmes évoqués
durant le débat une façon de déclencher
la prise de parole c'est pour
avoir une plus grande conscience de ce
qui se passe le mari il est parfois
considéré comme quelqu'un de très bien
quoi un type bien qui s'occupe de ses
enfants parce que lui fait face aussi ce
message via d'autres personnes donc
c'est trop facile pour que les gens les
prennent conscience mais il faut donner
un peu de la place aux pièces comme ça
justement le service de prévention et
sécurité de la ville de trappes a
rappelé les permanences de psychologues
un recueil avec les différentes
structures dead a été remis au public de
la culture pour toutes et tous
magny-les-hameaux vient de lancer son
portage culture une action pour l'année
au sein des foyers
le point avec le maire de la commune
bertrand aux lions déjà qu'est ce que le
portage culture le portage culture c'est
un principe assez simple on a l'habitude
de porter à domicile les repas par
exemple et bien là on apporte la culture
à domicile c'est à dire que c'est pas
les gens qui vont dans une salle de
spectacles qui vont à une exposition
c'est des morceaux de musique ou
peut-être à terme des livres ou d'autres
choses qui viennent chez les gens et
donc par exemple on peut avoir de la
flûte qui le flûte traversière bas qui
s'invite chez les gens pendant une demi
heure une heure et en même temps ça
permet de dialoguer autour d'un morceau
de musique
mais pourquoi vous avez mis cela en
place c'était une demande des habitants
une demande peut être des services un
besoin que vous avez identifié au fil du
temps fait il ya un besoin de lutter
face à l' isolement des personnes
on a mis un certain nombre de services
dans ce cadre là on a je le disais le
portage à domicile des repas qui existe
depuis de nombreuses années qui ne
concerne pas que des seniors qui
concerne vraiment toute personne qui
peut être isolé un moment donné par
exemple avec un handicap momentanée ou à
long terme
donc on a même des repas qui sont
confectionnés
ça permet aussi d'avoir un échange un
dialogue avec la personne qui les amène
on a également développé un réseau de
bénévoles qui viennent visiter les
personnes isolées pendant une demi-heure
une heure boire un café échange une part
de gâteau
parfois aussi ça va jusqu'à aider un
petit peu à faire les courses seco pour
les courses par exemple on les aide
aussi on les transporte ces personnes
qui qui n'ont pas forcément de trop de
moyens de déplacement
donc on a un certain nombre de
dispositifs comme ça qui permettent de
lutter contre l' isr contre l' isolement
et puis dans les réflexions qu'on a mené
avec le comité consultatif seniors dont
qui regroupe des habitants volontaires
pour pouvoir discuter de la politique
seniors sur la commune l'idée est venue
est venu de dire après tout plutôt que
de forcer des gens à aller sur des
spectacles où il n'aurait peut-être pas
forcément ils en ont pas forcément les
envies c'est pas forcément les bons
horaires pourquoi pas le ramener tout
simplement de la culture et l'idée est
venue de là et puis ensuite les services
de la commune ont travaillé dur tout ça
ont étudié les possibilités avec les
associations puisqu'il ya une démarche
citoyenne aussi parce que ce sont des
bénévoles qui le font sur la commune et
puis on a commencé à imaginer des
dispositifs qui permettent tout
simplement d'amener comme ça pendant une
heure la musique pour l'instant on en
est là c'est de la musique notamment
vous parlé d'association je sais que la
première à proposer ces les amis de la
flûte
un mot sur es qu'ils ont été partenaires
depuis le début de la pensée du projet
où ils sont arrivés un petit peu après
alors la réflexion du projet s'est fait
dans le cadre d'un comité consultatif
seniors donc avec principalement des
seigneurs qui sont investis pour pouvoir
justement imaginer des actions vis-à-vis
de leurs concitoyens et de cette
démarche donc on a proposé aux
associations culturelles de la commune
toutes ont un regard plutôt positif
après sa demande à être mis en place
les amis de la flûte qui est une
association encore récente sur la
commune donc qui est un regroupement
ondes
d'habitants qui qui font de la flûte
traversière et donc ils ont monté un
groupe en fait de flûte traversière ils
interviennent régulièrement sur des
animations de la commune est directement
plusieurs de leurs adhérents ont dit m
moi ça m'intéresse je veux bien
participer à cette à cette innovation
quand est-ce qu'on commence voilà c'est
voilà c'est de la démarche volontaire
tout simplement
et du coup ils ont nous ont même pris de
court parce qu'aujourd'hui on a donc les
des personnes qui sont volontaires pour
aller chez chez des gens proposait donc
un petit morceau de de musique
et puis et puis maintenant donc la
démarche va commencer pour pouvoir
trouver pour pouvoir répondre à des
besoins aussi de la part d'habitants
justement si un habitant est intéressé
quelles sont les démarches pour
accueillir les associés les associations
bénévoles
il ya plusieurs types de démarches
d'abord la personne elle même qui sont
isolées
contactez le service seniors de la
commune et ensuite on mettra en relation
présentera la personne bénévole qui
viendra qui viendrait chez eux
et puis après ça se fera tout simplement
il n'y a pas de démarche d'inscription
de choses compliquées à faire c'est
juste une mise en relation
après on peut aussi avoir le fait de
deux voisins qui voit qu'ils voient des
habitants qui leur semble un petit peu
isolé qui qui leur semblent pas
forcément en super forme aussi et ses
habitants là peuvent aussi nous nous
donner le contact nous le service
seniors ira faire la démarche ils
représentaient aussi notre mode de
fonctionnement et puis peut-être
qu'après ça donnera l'idée d'accepter ce
type de portage de culture à domicile et
pourquoi pas imaginer aussi des pièces
de théâtre des séances de lecture tout
est imaginable
on a déjà dans la réflexion certains
retours qu'ils nous disent pourquoi pas
partager la lecture venir avec des
bouquins échanger des bouquins dans ce
cadre là on a un certain nombre de
boîtes à livres qui qui ont été déployés
sur la commune mais maintenant au lieu
d'avoir la boîte alliés dans la gueule
dans la rue eh ben on irait chez les
gens et puis ça leur permet de discuter
de faire un petit peu de lecture voire
de lire des livres à des personnes qui
n'y aurait pas forcément la capacité de
les lire en termes de vue et
donc ça voilà c'est dans les réflexions
après encore une fois on peut tout
imaginer le tout c'est de créer de l'
échange autour d'une démarche de culture
de s'enrichir mutuellement
merci inverse trop brouillons alors pour
bénéficier du portage culture plusieurs
services de la ville sont concernés
il faut les contacter
[Musique]
à l'occasion des fêtes pourquoi pas ne
vous pourquoi ne pas vous replonger dans
les films disney dessinés 7 d'elancourt
vous propose trois rendez-vous avant
cendrillon et aladdin vous allez pouvoir
revivre les aventures de po caritas le
dimanche 16 décembre
c'était la fille d'un chef elle a
l'esprit de sa mère elle va partout où
le vent l'on porte l'histoire elle ne
connaissait que la liberté
voir
[Musique]
il est l explorateur la découverte du
nouveau on n'est pas venu jusqu'ici pour
rester à bord espérons qu'ils n'ont pas
l'intention de rester
veuillez bien ce que c'est moins que
rien ne perturbe pas notre mission
tout les séparait mais leur destinée à
vénérer
après pocahontas peter pan dans un
dortoir cinq adultes renou sur leur état
d'enfance et s'invente un monde
imaginaire autour de peter pan ou wendy
et le capitaine crochet jamais jamais
s'inspire librement des aventures
trépidantes du garçon qui ne veut pas
grandir
[Musique]
comment
on veut cette relance à pêche moi je
m'appelle toi comment
oh
ça y est je vole au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vous pourrez
vous émerveiller des prouesses des 22
acrobates de la compagnie xy
il n'est pas encore minuit s'interroge
sur le rapport du groupe de cheikhs 28
10 extraits
[Musique]
il décrypte la fait se côtoyaient pamela
anderson et bergson l'humoriste belge
alex vizorek et sur la scène du prix ce
modèle en cours ce samedi regardez là
c'est comme la politique c'est pas parce
qu'on n'y comprend rien qu'on ne peut
pas en fait sa ba dinh morano a bien
construit
lequel des deux est un tableau fauviste
il ya un piège
sachez que maléfique il n'était pas
hyper content de son travail
non mais et pourtant il n'avait pas
dépassé un spectacle ce soir on va
parfois apprendre des choses
et puis de temps en temps une petite
blague de culte pour récupérer tout vous
voyez à plaisir c'est une parodie qui
vous attend celle de ben mur avec un
regard humoristique et satirique la
pièce revisite le célèbre péplum à
découvrir au théâtre espace coluche la
guerre c'est la faiblesse des hommes la
paix et leur foire aux idées ils pas
compris moi prince de judée
je serai toujours là pour vous moi
prince de judée salahi revenus tu peux
comprendre
[Musique]
m
on sonne à la porte
c'est la fin de ce site une culture
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
mardi prochain
[Musique]